annalena baerbock vergisst fristgerecht
ihre nebeneinkünfte anzumelden im urlaub
feucht ist ein erfolg und armin laschet
was soll ich sagen am 26.9 sind
bundestagswahlen und nachdem ich mir
angeschaut habe wer zur wahl steht
wusste ich da ran muss etwas geändert
werden wir brauchen bezugspersonen in
der politik die verstehen was in der
jugend abgeht außerdem macht es mir spaß
einfach irgendwelche sachen aufzuhängen
die ich nicht anfangen darf und ich will
jeden von euch dazu animieren sich mit
der wahl auseinanderzusetzen und auch
wirklich wählen zu gehen vielleicht habt
ihr ja sogar schon vorher von diesem
video mitbekommen und gesehen was das
für wellen geschlagen hat viel spaß mit
ich habe fake wahlplakat auf
willkommen zum
ja ich habe mir eigentlich neu zu
erstehen lassen aber das ist nicht das
thema des videos denn wir im interesse
gesehen habt mir nicht viel platz aber
nicht irgendwelche wahlplakate sondern
mit den größten youtube und themen für
die sie stehen ob es liebe nicht
millionär
monte und regie für körper platte und
und noch viele weitere ich habe mir eine
menge coole sachen ausgedacht aber wie
sieht so ein typisches wahlplakat
eigentlich aus das müssen wir
herausfinden daran müssen uns
orientieren und dann geht's weiter mit
plakat design plakate aufhängen gucken
was dabei rumkommt also wieviel quasi
wie wir es bei dem eigene krippe
währungen gemacht haben wie viele leute
wir dazu bringen irgendwas dazu zu sagen
vielleicht bekommen ja die einzelnen
influenza sogar vorher schon davon mit
und im endeffekt geht es darum dass wir
eine menge spaß haben ganz kurz bevor es
wirklich mit dem video losgeht vergesst
nicht diesen kanal zu abonnieren ich
habe mir als ziel gesetzt dieses jahr
noch eine halbe million also 500.000
abonnenten zu schaffen ich würde mich
sehr freuen wenn ihr mich dabei
unterstützt und im kleinen ansporn zu
geben werde ich von jedem wahlplakat das
wir haben 1 verlosen also schreibt in
die kommentare welche sie am liebsten
hätte und man suche ich mir fünf leute
raus
als allererstes müssen wir anfangen zu
recherchieren und herausführt wie machen
es die anderen erfolgreichen parteien so
dass wir uns was von den abschauen
können und einfach deren stil übernehmen
so dass unsere plakate in dem ganz
normalen dschungel der wahlplakate
untergehend mit einfließen und für
unsere message nicht unsere message ist
sondern die messages der
influenza die das alles natürlich
abgesegnet haben und alle davon wissen
das genau das passiert statt mit fdp und
scheinbar es ist hier trumpf einfach
christian lindner hat auch zupacken und
irgendwie kranke statement mit
digitalisierung für mehr freude am
erfinden als am verbieten und so weiter
ja gut also statement ein gesicht das
wir kennen und der parteiname cdu
wahlplakate zack zack ja wie ein
schlecht ich das jetzt funktioniert
gemeinsam für ein modernes deutschland
betraf
die wahlplakate burka ich stehe mehr
aufbruch gründen
ja das problem ist bei den fw walter
karten kann ich wirklich nicht
einschätzen ob sich irgend jemandem spaß
erlaubt hat also einen schlechten spaß
oder ob die das ernst meint also bei der
ft werden wir uns wenig ab schauen denn
diese leute wollen wir nicht erreichen
spd da sollten wir uns wahrscheinlich
auch nichts ab schaut aus wir wollen
dass unsere kampagne nicht 50 zählt ja
also es ist alles das gleiche vielleicht
also es ist wirklich leicht zu
durchschauen bis auf die linke werden
alle mit einem slogan und einem
bekannten gesicht am tag paarmal
ausdrucken auf die straße und fertigt
etwas wir uns entscheiden wen nehmen wir
welche themen welche slogans und was
macht am meisten fanden wo kann das
drucken und dann raus damit also munter
definitiv rentenpolitik oder das steuern
der steuerrückzahlung von
karstadt-immobilien richtig schön auf
kapitalismus
wer schreibt sich so ein thema so
wichtig auf die fahne ins co irgendwann
während hartmann wieder erlaubt pro liga
schon einiges was für ein thema krieg
papi aufnahme von anglizismen in den
duden
das ist aber einfach nur ein zeichen
dass ein krankes aufhäuser ich glaube
eine menge sachen die ziemlich gut
passen könnten jetzt gilt es nur noch
das zu design irgendwie ein
einheitliches muster zu bringen das auf
wahlplakate zu buchen und damit richtig
schön kochen
wir haben in den letzten tagen sehr viel
arbeit da reingesteckt die plakate so
gut und witzig wie möglich zu gestalten
und jetzt gilt ist sie zu drucken ich
werde aber ich die noch nicht zeigen ich
zeige euch dass wenn wir die im heck
dann wirklich aufhängen und ich werde
noch mal ein bisschen genauer darauf
eingehen denn es sind nicht nur plakate
sondern die plakate verlinken
irgendwohin die plakate sind auf die
personen angepasst mit denen wir für
eigene für sie vorgesehene parteien
werden es wird also ein absoluter traum
die werden gerade angerufen habe keine
wahl plakate drucken lassen wollen
würden worauf für außen
hoch die sein so 25 die seite sind fünf
nicht soweit der tag gekommen auf dem
wir so lange gewartet haben die
wahlplakate sind da
wenn ich das richtig verstanden haben
sollte sind das tatsächlich tägliche
wahlplakat also nicht irgendwie normale
plakat oder irgendwie sowas sondern so
wichtige genau so wie man sie kennt
damit plakate sich auch im
großstadtdschungel vernünftig einpflegen
und jetzt nicht besonders auffallen wenn
man nicht genau auf gibt also genau so
wie sie sein soll
[Musik]
also das wird sich definitiv nicht im
großstadtdschungel wegen also das feld
komplett aus da die weit weg ist wie
fühlt es sich an sich gut dass du willst
ein wahlplakat soll ich dazu sagen
johanna jäger das sieht richtig gut aus
das sieht wirklich so aus als könnte es
einfach immerhin montana vielleicht nein
zu 50 prozent an fahrer sofort
steuersenkungen wichtig richtig und der
link verlinkt immer zu den besten
momenten mit unseren liebsten politikern
richtig verschlossen hält
mein gott wie bussen waren war es gar
nichts zu bezahlen das ist ein richtiges
statement christopher jonas klaus
besonderen hat zu sagen sie uns endlich
mal wählbare politiker zwei plakate
fehlen noch 11 von reviews von re wies
auch wirklich 10 15 vielleicht brauche
ich dafür ein paar wahlhelfer um die
überall in der stadt zu verteilen denn
das wird eine menge aufwand
seitdem wir die plakate gerade
vorbereitet haben gilt es jetzt den
richtigen platz zu finden und natürlich
müssen die plakate irgendwohin wo
möglichst viele leute davon mitbekommen
denn wir brauchen stimmen für montage-
reparatur-
und für deren parteien und natürlich
habe ich mir dafür nichts geringeres
ausgedacht als die schildergasse wir
sind kurz vor dem wochenende und das ist
eine der bestbesuchten
einkaufsstraßen in komplett deutschland
und natürlich die bestbesuchte straße
auch in köln es wird ein fest aller
oberstes ziel wäre natürlich dass
irgendwelche leute davon in stories
tecdax machen und sich das schon
verbreitet bevor dieses video online
kommt aber mal sehen jetzt heißt es
wir sind mitten am neumarkt einer der
meistbesuchten plätze überhaupt in köln
dreh und angelpunkt für alles was mit
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln zu tun hat
die sind wirklich eine menge leute jetzt
sind wir nach den besten plätzen um alle
plakate auch zeiten da sich und olaf
scholz wir brauchen eigentlich starke
positionen
stolz mich erfüllt ein tiefer stolz
kompetenz für deutschland olaf scholz
und darunter montana black nein zu 50
prozent an vater staat und der link wird
zur hölle führt
das problem daran wenn wir plakate
niedrig hängen natürlich wird es leute
geben die diese plakate mit nehmen
deswegen müssen wir ein bisschen weiter
nach oben
das ist können wir uns nicht gefallen
lassen
passt doch das politische deutschland
umstrukturiert wir kommen jetzt ganz
nach oben und
regieren hier
dann noch zwei drei plakate die werden
auch krank aber die leute sind schon
fleißig und guckt man dann fotos man es
ist ein traum genau so wie es mir
vorgestellt habe los jetzt gerade sind
die ganzen schüler noch in der schule
wir haben irgendwie 10.30 und in drei
stunden wird sie noch mal deutlich
voller und da kommen die leute die die
tik tok auf dem handy installiert haben
und man jetzt weiter ja und was
wochenende und dann kommt das wochenende
deswegen einmal alle drei übereinander
alle drei die wir dabei haben damit die
leute auf einen blick komplett sehen was
in politik deutschland gerade ganz oben
an der spitze um wählbar ist wie machen
wir das ding einmal komplett voll und
dann
[Musik]
die plakate hin keine fünf stunden und
direkt wurden die ersten sachen online
gepostet erst revier auf twitter dann
soll ich auf tik tok und dann monte
selbst auf twitter und instagram man
kann also sagen das ding war ein voller
erfolg haben also jede menge leute
gesehen und wir wollen diese
aufmerksamkeit nutzen um zu sagen geht
wählen und nutzt eure stimme am 26.9
sinnvoll es liegt an uns die richtigen
leute zu werden und nicht wundern hier
spricht leo der kater von dave dave
sitzt gerade auf kreta und hat enorm
schlechtes internet weswegen er die
abmoderation nicht hochladen kann aber
hat euch das video gefallen hat was ein
leichter und abonniert diesen kanal um
nichts mehr zu verpassen und wenn ihr
ein wahlplakat gewinnen wollt dass wir
euch zu senden das schreibt einfach
gerne in die kommentare welches ihn
gerne haben würde und versuchen uns fünf
leute aus bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
das von ihr nicht komplett raus